welcome to episode 75 of film courage my
name is karen warden my name is David
Brannon we are thrilled very thrilled to
have actor taka tell here in studio with
us he's a longtime friend he is one of
the most dedicated actors that we know
you're gonna soon see him in the movie
goodbye promise and we'd also like to
mention that he is the guy who inspired
the film courage moniker so you know if
you will so welcome this is one way we
give back to him thank you for joining
us here in studio it's a pleasure to be
here David and Karen really and on our
featured guest today is one of the most
praised directors of independent cinema
John's lengthy list of projects include
me Tuan passion fish the brother from
another planet honey dripper eight men
out Sunshine State and many more
incredible films indeed John Sayles
latest work is entitled amigo which
premieres at the 35th Toronto
International Film Festival on Tuesday
September 14th that's two days from
today in addition to filmmaking John is
an author of screenplays short stories
plays and several books including a new
novel entitled a moment in the Sun set
around 1900 it's the same era as the
movie amigo also in the Philippines
which is going to be published by
McSweeney's in May of 2011
please welcome to the film courage
program mr. John Sayles hello John how
you doing doing well you know pleased to
have once again we are thrilled to have
you join us here today John thank you
all right well thank you again John for
joining us today
now you've been a storyteller for many
years how old were you when you began
writing stories oh I was probably about
8 or 10 when I could start to write and
I just I mostly wrote stories about the
kids in my neighborhood having
adventures that were ripped off from the
TV series begun touchable so somehow the
kids in this very rural neighborhood in
byrne Hills New York were fighting the
Capone mob hmm interesting okay
and from watching your films and
listening to your various interviews you
know we've gathered that you have an
incredibly clear grasp on human beings
and the world around you and you show
this quality in your work without
judgement of your subjects I mean we
always like this were you a keen
observer as a child yeah well you know
it's I think the observer comes out of
being curious you know I've often said
that you know both the fiction that I
write and the movies that I've made a
lot of it comes from this feeling of if
this is the way people are acting what
could possibly be going on in their
heads so I I think I've always you know
including in my fiction and as well in
the movies been interested in not
necessarily judging people but figuring
out why they're doing what they're doing
okay you know and putting them in a in a
dramatic situation where they sometimes
have to do some you know make some
difficult choices and I also read that
you went to Williams College in
Massachusetts and a great education
however you shunned most corporate jobs
and weren't curious about this it seemed
that you were attracted to more
industrious work and well I wouldn't say
shown is the word I got a corporate job
when I got up you know I got out of
college in 1972 with a you know BA in
Psychology which was not especially
useful you know and so I and I had been
working you know since I was in high
school summers you know just to make
money so I went back to immediately went
back to what I'd done before working in
factories and hospitals so one day
actually shining I just got the best job
that I could and then eventually I got
lucky and a couple years after I was out
of college I got a union job as a meat
packer and which paid probably about
four times what minimum wage back then
was about a dollar a dollar ten an hour
and meatpacking at least the job that I
got was was about 440 an hour so that
was a huge step up for me
and and also kind of meant that I was
able to you know start writing a little
bit more because they had a little a
little less scuffling around for money
this is film cards and Elly talked
radio.com we are on the line with
filmmaker John Sayles whose new movie
amigo is having his world premiere at
the Toronto International Film Festival
on September 14th and once again that's
in two days John you are Apple if ik
rider bouncing off your own scripts to
Hollywood rewrites two novels you know
an almost every writer that we know is
also an avid reader you know do you read
more than you write you know I don't get
to read just fiction as much as I'd like
to I do an awful lot of research reading
for screenwriting jobs enemies are doing
or auditioning for because you have to
audition for a screenwriting job these
days and some of that's really really
interesting for my novel moment in the
Sun I probably read a hundred books a
few of them in Spanish just to feel like
I was well grounded enough to write
about certain things so I get to do that
kind of reading but just reading for fun
I really get to do any more I used to do
a lot more of it and it's something that
you know if I'm unemployed I actually
get to do a little bit John this is Todd
here I just had a quick question about
what you said when you say you have to
audition for for one of the writing jobs
or just kind of surprising given your
your resume but nonetheless when you say
that what do you do you provide a
certain sample that they want and in
that particular know you can't really
write anything down on paper without
them hired you yeah I'm in the the
screenwriters guild the Writers Guild of
America East what what the the general
way that people get screenwriting jobs
these now these days is your name is put
up for a job and it may be a rewrite it
may be an original it may be a polish
even by your agent and usually the
studio involved will talk
five six seven eight depending on how
much patience they have for the process
different writers and they want to hear
your take on it they want to hear what
you would do if you were the writer and
you know that can be and in my case
because I don't live in Los Angeles an
hour or two sometimes on the phone
sometimes talking back and forth
sometimes you just do your pitch this is
the way I see this you know thing you
know being structured or whatever and
quite honestly you you usually never
hear from them again and they they may
hire yet another writer that they didn't
you know they may be taking notes and
say oh that was very interesting and
that's it and you know keep some of your
ideas and you know it's it's not
something that writers like but it's
pretty much the way you get work now or
at least the way that I get work now
right and John how much time do you
generally devote to writing each of your
stories I mean you tend to focus on one
project at a time or are you
consistently overlapping projects
because I imagine you know if I'm lucky
and unwell employed usually what happens
is just because of the reading period
that it takes people to take I usually
have two going on at any one time and so
you know I hand one in and they'll take
two three four weeks to read it and
respond to it and in that time I'm
writing the other one I actually write
very fast when I know what I'm doing I
know what I'm doing if I've done the
research but also the the speed with
which I can write also depends on the
meetings that I've had with the people
who are you know paying for the
screenplay and how clear they've been
able to be if they're just fishing if
their statements are very vague then it
takes you longer because you're really
inventing the story if they're you know
I've written the screenplays I did a
rewrite once of a modern-day samurai
movie in three days because the
producers needed in three days to get a
certain actor to give a green light to
the project so they could you know get
to make it generally how
write a screenplay in about two weeks
put it aside not think about it for a
week and then pick it up and do you know
my own rewrite on it before I send it in
so you know it really varies with with
the mandate that I've been given but I'm
lucky in that what you know once I know
where I'm going I write pretty fast
Johnson your films are remarkably
diverse and it would seem that diversity
emerges from your insatiable cultural
curiosity and fascination with human
nature could you speak specifically to
what has triggered those moments within
you when you decide to invest a year or
more of your life and telling a
particular story on film yeah I think it
boils down to interest and the interest
may have been there for years and years
and years and years you know you
mentioned Lone Star before
Lone Star kind of probably began when I
watched you know Davy Crockett on the
wonderful world of Disney when I was a
little kid right and had this this one
idea of what the story of the Alamo was
and then the first time I got to go to
San Antonio and went to see the real
Alamo there was a demonstration outside
of it of mexican-americans basically
saying what let's hear the whole story
and then I got interested in the story
of the Alamo and and eventually I
started thinking about first of all
Texas which is its own deal right you
know Texas was a republic for nine years
or so and and there's a lot of people
who still feel like you know it's an
ally of the United States not
necessarily one of the United States I
got thinking about Texas but also the
the legends of Texas and what happens
when a legend starts to be destructive
rather than constructive you know what
why do we have legends and what happened
you know can they cause trouble as well
as be a wonderful thing that tells us
who we are and and that kind of ended up
sparking into well what if what if I was
to do something on the Texas border and
deal with that thing
of you know what what people think their
past was as opposed to what it really
was right well then so so it may be a
long process you know certainly this
this movie amigo that we're going to be
premiering at the Toronto Film Festival
tomorrow
I wrote a screenplay that that had to do
with that era maybe 15 years ago I put
it aside because it was clear we were
never going to get enough money to make
that ambitious a screenplay then I
started thinking well you know if I made
it into a novel I could expand it rather
than trying to squeeze even more into a
two-hour period and then I went back on
a trip to the Philippines to look at
some of the places that were mentioned
in the novel and get it you know to see
them with my own eyes rather than just
read about them and I started talking to
our friend Joel Torre was a very
well-known Filipino actor about
Philippine movies and how much they cost
and realized you know I could make a
movie set in that era a kind of micro
history and and if we did all our
shooting and post in the Philippines
actually afford to make a fairly
ambitious movie for a fairly low budget
you know and and and that kind of
started leading to the idea for a story
so you and your scripts are quite
meticulously structured it would seem
and it is my guess that the the dialogue
we hear when sitting in the theater is
essentially verbatim to that which you
wrote on the page and yet there is an
inherently authentic and sort of
seamlessly spontaneous quality to the
Caracara Kerr interactions on screen in
your films would you share a bit about
the collaborative process with your
actors in general that allows for that
authenticity and in particular with your
stalwarts Chris Cooper David Strathairn
and Kris Kristofferson among others yeah
what I thing is hire good actors that
healthy helps you know I I don't tend to
change lines or or have you know actors
ad-lib or paraphrases even on the set
you know I'll write everything at least
everything in
English down and really look on it one
of the things that I do is I was an
actor before I was a writer a director I
go through and I play every part you
know I just I just kind of highlight you
know one characters you know dialogue
and I say okay if I had to play this
part now that I said these lines out
loud is there enough there am i an
interesting person do I know where I'm
coming from
and so usually the secondary characters
get a you know it may be only two more
lines or they may end up being related
to somebody else in the movie and you
know I draw a couple more connective
lines to anchor that character in the
story a little bit more then one of the
things that I do in the process is I
write a bio for every character if you
have two lines you get a short bio if
you have if you're the lead you probably
get a three page you know bio but it's
the stuff that that might be helpful to
an actor about who the character is
where they just came from what they
think about things that are not
necessarily spelled out in the script
and I think might be helpful and those
bios go to those actors that's uh as
soon as we cast them so they could have
them for weeks or months or in the case
of our movies where the money falls
apart years right and and then I just
say call me up if you have a question so
for two reasons one is that I don't do
rehearsals
I don't do even a read-through I don't
have the money to pay the actors for one
thing or I'll get them all in the same
room because they come from all over the
country or all over the world in some
cases and the other is that I want that
kind of shock of the new there I want to
put a bunch of actors who absolutely
know who their characters are who are
good hard-working actors and they know
their lines and everything I want them
to put them in that situation and it is
absolutely harder to do take ten as new
and as surprised and and as fresh as it
is to do take one agree Lord Tyrion is
fantastic it's just one of the tough you
know as opposed to theater acting where
you know you get this great thing of you
you you know the play and every night is
different cause it's a different
audience and everything but you only do
it once that night you don't go back and
and you know there's directors who you
know until they hear some strange notes
that only they can hear they'll have you
do it over and over and over and over
and over and maybe they're trying to
break down what you usually do but it
usually means that they can't articulate
what they want I'm much more of the
school of I'm going to do it two or
three times and each time I'm going to
make a you know give a direction to the
actor and and that that's all it is is
well let's go left instead of light or
try to hide your anger a little bit more
this time or whatever and then I usually
just say to the actor okay I'm happy
I've got what I need for the editing
room is there anything you want to do or
can think of that you want to do that
you haven't done you you know and then
you may do one or two more for the actor
right well that's that's yeah that's a
dream come true for an actor right there
it sounds like a pleasure yeah and then
and then the other thing that that I
really concentrate on is actors need
other actors support to support them so
you know what what you try to do is I
always think of it as being the corner
man for two fighters but you're the
corner man for both fighters and what
you want is a good lively fight so I
tend to take the actors separately and
say okay this time you know don't let
your mother push you around forever and
then you may change the dynamic from to
the mother and you're not tricking them
you're just you're just giving them each
something to come into the ring with
that's slightly different than the last
time so you've changed the dynamic and
you know and then you just see what
happens with that new dynamic and so
really what you want your actors doing
is not looking to you but taking care of
business with the other people who are
on screen with them you know and and
that's the great thing about working
with good actors is they really play off
each other and if the actor throws
something different Adams they've got a
react to it
a different way right and and as there
are those those bits of direction that
you're giving take to take is that
coming for you spontaneously and that
mama toward you along with writing out
the BIOS and sort of acting out the
scenes that you've written in each part
do you do you make those decisions and
say I have a list of five or six things
I'm going to suggest to David or to
Chris and you know I almost never do
really the the first thing you want to
do is see what the actors are going to
come up with themselves because it may
not be something that you have thought
of mmm I like it a whole lot better than
what you have right so so so all that
prep is before we get to the set and
then it's just K okay you know you tried
to do a no acting rehearsal so that
people you know don't wander off you
know out of where the camera can keep
them in focus but but you know you're
not really talking about the dynamics of
the scene yet until you see people do it
a couple times and I use an awful lot of
first take stuff you know because the
actors come up with something really
interesting and they won't necessarily
do it again you know there are actors
who are brilliant on the first take and
then they start to second-guess
themselves what you eventually try to do
is handicap the actors and you know like
Chris Cooper is an actor who you can
have him with a camera behind him for
three-quarters of the day doing a long
scene and just say Chris you know just
okay use this time but we're not gonna
point at your face until about halfway
through the afternoon and then he'll
have used that time and it'll be
terrific when you turn around the point
of him and he'll have really helped the
other actor through the scene there are
other actors who you really you really
just say okay you know what you're doing
let's go and you get one or two great
takes out of them and then you say I
loved it and we're not gonna place
Cameron at you anymore because they're
starting to second-guess themselves and
you know get self-conscious or whatever
and you you have to learn that about
actors very quickly so you know how to
cover a scene in a way that's going to
be the best for each of the actors in
the scene do you find that the
because they're aware of that themselves
not necessarily um actors all I always
ask an actor how do you like to work and
how do you work best and some of them
are very self-aware and others really
don't want to be self-aware and you try
to help that you know there's error
actors who say oh give me a line reading
I don't care I'll make it my own and
others where you don't really want to
finish a sentence with them because then
they're going to feel too constrained
and you know you're there to direct
their talents not teach them how to act
you know you wouldn't hire them if you
didn't think they could act right the
other thing that that is difficult as a
director is that you've you know in my
case I've written these lines in in some
cases I've heard them said by you know
50 people in auditions so I've seen that
scene 50 times with actors not even the
ones who are going to be in the movie in
it right is to have it be new to you so
one of the things that I do is I do a
lot of prep so that I know what I want
out of the day and then I try to just
like a good actor does between takes or
between shows if they're on theaters
forget everything and just come to it
very new and say okay are these people
making me watch them what's going on
here what do I feel could I get more out
of this thing on amigo you know half um
half of the dialogue is in Tagalog I
don't speak and he took all along I
wrote the dialogue and English and then
a really good you know writer and
screenwriter over there people cava
translated it into deep to dog tagalog
tagalog that people might have spoken in
1900 and you know keeping in mind who
was educated and who wasn't and all
those other kind of character things as
I had given them but when the actors
were acting I didn't really understand
line by line exactly what they were
saying and I would have to say to them
well if you blow a line you're gonna
have to tell me or you know tell that to
my first ad or some of the other people
who did speak Tagalog on the set I'm
just listening for emotion here and
listening for the dynamics of the scene
and and I found that I had no
problem directing without understanding
what the language was you know and in
fact it was easier in some ways distract
it by the word John I had a friend say
to me the other day that one of the
greatest achievements in the life of an
artist is the day that you can walk away
from your day job and pursue your artful
time how do you respond to that it is
great I mean I I wrote my first novel on
unemployment insurance and they
eventually you know the Christmas season
had ended and they didn't need as many
meat packers to put out the amount of
you know brought Daisy and pepperoni
that we were making and so I got laid
off and for I think it was twenty four
weeks
I got a whopping I think it was $42 a
week which was just enough to pay the
rent and eat and so for those weeks I
had just gotten an offer to expand
extend a short story of mine into a
novel by Atlantic Monthly press and so I
was able to sit in my freezing kitchen
and just write and then I had to go back
to work you know laughter I handed the
novel and that lasted for a couple years
eventually what happened is I threw the
novels that I had written which I was
writing while I had factory and Hospital
jobs
I got a offer from you know a Hollywood
screenplay agent to come out and write
screenplays and probably within about
three months of getting to Santa Barbara
I got a screen screenwriting job for
Roger Corman and got paid $10,000 for
cuz he was a signatory to the Writers
Guild and that was what minimum was in
those days which was probably about
$2,000 more than I'd ever made in one
year and you know it was like a
two-month job at the most and then I
continued to get screenwriting jobs so
you know that that became my job and you
know it is a job it's not writing
my own stuff but it beats the other
things how this does it certainly pays
better and so in terms of you know how
much you make per hour it's a lot better
than even the meatpacking job and it has
some other benefits your your your
you're working with the muscles that
you're gonna use to write your own stuff
you have a different mandate which is
when you're writing a screenplay for
other people
you're there to tell their story it's
not your story and you're working as a
technician but you use almost all the
same storytelling muscles that you use
for yourself and maybe even some more
that you don't use for yourself because
you you have to sell it a little bit
more when you're writing for other
people and I'm one of the few directors
I know who's met all these other
directors and actually gotten to work
with them directors don't get to work
with other directors writers get to work
with director so you know I've gotten to
work with you know Ron Howard and
Jonathan Demi and Sydney and
John Frankenheimer and you know the list
goes on and on Steven Spielberg James
Cameron you know and and gotten this
little window into at least in the story
period how they think how they plan a
movie which is a is a you know a great
kind of kind of benefit of the you know
the screenwriting gig you know you
mentioned Roger Corman there I mean you
know how big how big was that you know
the fact that you were hired for piranha
you know was that well well was huge in
that I got to make a living right away
and also it's very rare for a
screenwriter to write three screenplays
and half three movies made I mean Roger
was if nothing else an economical
producer and so if he had somebody he'd
paid somebody ten thousand dollars to
write a screenplay
it wasn't gonna it was gonna pay anybody
else anymore he was gonna make that you
know just kind of hand it to the
director and say do what he can with
this
so I groped three screenplays for Roger
in about
a year and a half two years maybe and
they all got made so I got two I was on
the set for a day on two of them I got
to see the movie see what worked what
didn't talk to the directors you know
get an idea of what was labor intensive
and what was capital intensive you know
what costs money and what can you just
do with you know good work and lots of
it and a little kind of you know tricky
cleverness you know of how we're going
to do this with less money than we
really need to do this so in that in
that way it was a great school of you
know I didn't go to film school but I
did work for Roger Corman and it was you
know the other great thing about it at
that time anyway is that there there
there wasn't the pressure on it that
there is working on a studio movie
studio movies cost so much that if your
name is going on them and it's it's a
failure
somehow that gets attached to your name
nobody was paying attention to these B
movies at that time they didn't get
reviewed generally so the critics
weren't paying attention to him and even
you know variety would kind of list them
but they were usually under the radar of
you know the business as it's called so
that there just wasn't that kind of oh
god we have to look at every single word
here you know it just in case somebody
in Peoria may not like it and if that
opportunity never came along to write
those movies for Roger I mean how much
longer would it have taken you to sort
of break into the movie industry do you
think oh you know who knows you know you
never know you might never have broken
in you know I was I was not you know
living in Los Angeles I was living up
and Santa Barbara I wasn't going to
parties you know I had written a couple
things on spec but you know mostly there
were things I wanted to direct myself so
I was very lucky but there was that in
you know I might have started working
for TV and it would have been a longer
apprenticeship so it was great to get a
bunch of features written and made that
quickly and then very soon after that I
wrote
couple movies for people who had been
directors at Corman who had you know a
slightly higher budget you know outside
of his studio and I did a couple
rewrites for them so I got into the you
know onto the list of you know kind of
acceptable writers pretty quickly
an interesting thing that happens though
is that you get typecast as a writer
just as you do you know an actor so I
had written horror movies and for a long
time I only got offered other horror
movies to write and then I wrote and
directed this movie return of the
Secaucus seven and people said oh he
does human beings too and then I started
getting you know some you know offers
for movies that there were just human
beings and then nothing large that could
eat them and you mentioned parties a few
minutes ago and that segues perfectly
into our next question because I had
read something where I think you asked
HarperCollins not to throw a party for
you I don't know if that's correct or
not but you know many creative people
including myself are more reclusive
however you know networking is so
important of course to a budding artists
career how does one fight through that
urge to hibernate when really they need
to get out there and be social and
spread the news of their project well I
think what what you what you try to
figure out is is there a person you can
be who can do that
you know don't play somebody who you're
not going to be able to play again and
and it may be it may be a strain but you
know going in see there might be
somebody interesting to talk there you
know it's it's I did not go to film
school and when I talk at film schools
you know I I kind of say you know I
could have used about a week of film
school there were about five technical
things I wish I knew when I directed my
first movie and other than that I don't
think I really needed to help that film
school would have done except I often
see people who met at film school and
continue to work together who just they
felt the same about films you know when
you know Ernest Dickerson and Spike Lee
Ernest Ernest shot a lot of
Spike's early movies and he shot some of
the boost springsteen videos and brother
from another talent planet for me you
know they really bonded in film school
and came out and it was a huge help to
Ernest Dickerson to have Spike Lee you
know pick him as his cinematographer
early on and have something to show that
was the real movie and it was a huge
help to Spike Lee to have somebody as
good as Ernest Dickerson's who was good
right away as a cinematographer shoot
his first movie so there were a lot more
presentable and professional-looking
than often you get right out of film
school you know I know a lot of people
who have come out of films go on you
know in the first movies people kind of
do everything and then after two or
three movies that kind of settle down
and say well you know what I am it's
really I'm an editor or I'm a producer
or I'm a director or sometimes what you
find is you know I've had at least two
maybe three yeah three of my script
supervisors have gone on to be directors
you know so it may be that okay this is
what I'm doing on this movie you know I
know a lot of young people right now who
are making movies and it's just like
well he was a cinematographer on my
movie and he needs somebody to you know
be a grip on this one you know and you
go and you do it as long as you can
afford to and as long as you can stand -
and David and I were discussing the
other day that there are certain careers
where you follow a specific course of
action and you get a TA you achieve a
planned result for instance if you want
to be a doctor you know it's going to be
at least eleven years of school you know
four years of med school three years
working in hospital and after all that
effort you get the payoff however the
pursuit of filmmaking as a career is not
promised you know someone can finish
film school as we talked about earlier
but there's no telling what will happen
when it's done there's no certainty you
know and so many people they they dream
of being involved with films but they
chase another profession where there's
just more certainty how do we as
filmmakers and artists deal with this
uncertainty both professionally and
psychologically you know that results
from following this path how do we deal
with the unknown
I I think that you you have to embrace
it and endure it because it's not always
fun you know I really don't generally
know from movie to movie if I'm ever
going to make it another one again you
know we haven't had anybody invest in
our movies for the last three or four
movies we've had to raise the money
ourselves you know and that means I've
been writing a lot of screenplays for
other people and even that market is
kind of drying up for me so you know I
don't know if I'm going to just make
another movie that's not new however
it's saying some breaking your heart
there wasn't some some golden age when I
knew I could get you know money for
movies so you you know that uncertainty
that's what you know that's what
songwriters go through that's what
visual artists go through you know
painters go through its this is what I
want to do and if I if there's something
else that I can do that I'll like better
or if I just can't stand the uncertainty
then you go do that other thing but you
know it's it's it's nobody puts a gun to
your head and says you have to be in an
independent filmmaker or an avant-garde
artist of any sort or even have a rock
band you do it because there are the
thing itself is a reward you like doing
the thing itself and that and that may
only last a certain amount of time and
they last until you're out of graduate
school you know or it may last until
you're 40 you know it may last until
your third kid or your second marriage
but you know if you're lucky you kind of
keep that thing and yeah I I think most
people who continue to even if they're
very successful create good stuff in
whatever field it's because they still
have stories they want to tell or
paintings they want to paint and and
that's what they want to do yeah I I
wrote a script that you know who knows
that well if it will ever get made into
a movie a rewrite on a script about
Salvador Dali and you know with all his
kind of Paul
like you know posturing it is wax
mustache and all that which was his pose
because he was painfully almost
pathologically shy he had to play that
part he still worked eight to ten hours
a day painting even when he wasn't that
you know he was just famous and and you
know he was passed the spine maybe as an
artist that's what he wanted to do with
paint this is film courage we are on the
line right now with filmmaker John
Sayles we have our close friend actor
Todd Cattell here in studio with us you
know John being a professional filmmaker
it's not it's not just mastering
storytelling in the art of filmmaking
you also have to handle the business
side of things which includes
distribution you know and every
filmmaker you know especially all the
ones tuned in right now you know we're
all desperately trying to figure out the
distribution side of things
the hood the club the whole landscape is
you know it's changed dramatically you
know and especially in the last few
years you know what light can you share
you know what wisdom can you pass on to
filmmakers who are looking to follow in
your path well you know each time we
make a movie it's about you know even
when we're really kind of in the thick
of it it would be a movie every two
years let's say or a year and a half by
the time that next movie is ready to go
the landscape has changed totally
you know the business has changed
totally and that that has been true
since the very beginning so right now I
would say there really is not an
independent movie business there are a
few distributors left next year or two
years from now if there's you know eight
of them now six of those names will be
different um you know the things you
know these companies go in and out of
business very very quickly it's a very
volatile kind of little industry and to
the point where it's not really even a
sustainable industry anymore you know
films sometimes somehow get on a screen
somehow make a lot of money some some of
that money goes back to the filmmakers
and
you know all you need is one hit like
that and as a distribution company
you're good for a couple of years you
can pay your staff and your rent and
whatever for a couple years so there's
still that that dream but there's just
not as many of those movies they don't
stay in the theaters long enough to you
know because partly because there's so
many of them but partly just because the
audience for them has shrunk they don't
stay in the theaters long enough to
return enough that there are as many
people who have a lot of money who are
interested investing in independent
films so I think that the future is less
left to be invented the question is you
know and and you know there's some
argument that you know independent film
makers will mostly always be first and
second time filmmakers because they
don't have to make money back there
working with their friends who aren't in
the Screen Actors Guild yet who might be
interesting actors or interesting you
know faces or whatever and they're not
working with crews who have families and
and lifestyles to support so they're not
working with Union people so they can
make a movie for you know $100,000 or
$200,000 or even less the minute you
start to work with professionals you
know people who are in the Screen Actors
Guild or you know the you know the
various craft unions I a people or
whatever it's pretty hard to make
something under a million it's pretty
hard to even make anything under five
million and then you better have a
theatrical distribution and all the
ancillary is to try to make some of that
money back so you know it there is
another kind of filmmaking possible it's
just that it's unlikely to be done on a
professional level where the people
actually make a living wage because the
returns from new media have just been so
low but you can make movies and you can
make good movies it's just that the hope
to make a living at it
you know I I kind of feel like in the
future there used to be this phenomenon
of the ski bum who are these guys who
could you know kind of find a cheap
place to live and Aspen or Vail or
whatever and they kind of just followed
the snow around and give lessons and you
know kind of live off the the largesse
of the rich people who did their skiing
I think in the future they're going to
be film bums you know who kind of are
able to sustain it until they're 40 and
their knees go over there their nerve
goes or whatever but they won't exactly
make a living at it but they might make
a lot of good movies we have a question
that's come in from our friend and also
prior guest Cheri canler and it's in the
same vein do you see there being more
opportunities or less in the near future
for indie filmmakers to get their film
seen is the answer in pursuing
distribution companies or in creating
your own audience and platforms for your
work so basically either you are the
studio or you need a studio well you
know I've always felt like you know you
you don't have to just seize the means
of production you have to seize the
means of distribution in the exhibition
as well I go back to this thing of yes
absolutely I think if you want your
stuff seen and the mainstream very
narrow bottleneck you have to go through
is too narrow for you to get your movie
through it there are ways to get your
stuff seeing it's just that you can't
make a living on it certainly there
should be more clubs that show movies
certainly there should be more movie
theaters that have something like a
bibliothèque where you can get just just
go in and and watch you know non
mainstream stuff you know on on video
it's not necessarily with a big crowd
certainly there should be all these
other alternative ways to see movies and
I think filmmakers will end up just as
you know for years and years and years
theater groups have formed when they
could get a loft or whatever and they
put it on in the law because somebody's
father owns the building or
you know there's there's a nice
superintendent and we'll let them use it
as long as they you know kind of clean
up after themselves I don't think it's
viable as a career to make a living but
I think it's very viable if you just
want people to see your you know
whatever work you made also you're known
to take money that you make as a script
doctor on studio features and pour that
money into your own personal work so if
you took away the Hollywood income and
any monies that you make from your books
or short stories basically if we
narrowed it down to the only money that
you've made you know would it be from
your independent films I mean is the
only way to make a living as an
independent filmmaker to have bread and
butter coming from another outlet it
depends I mean there are people you know
I'm not one of them who you know studios
asked them to direct their movies they
get paid a lot for it I'm not one of
them so I think for a lot of filmmakers
that's true it's not for every filmmaker
you know I think you know if if you can
see commercial movies being made that
you'd be happy making and think that you
do a good job making that's something to
take a whack at you know I know some
very good filmmakers who are able to you
know I know the Coen brothers are able
to you know kind of work almost in the
system there's other people make very
very good interesting movies it's rare
that they have the kind of control that
the Coen brothers have over their movies
but you know that's worth taking a whack
at if you think okay these are
mainstream you know my ideas are
mainstream enough that a lot of people
would want to see him and I could work
in that system if not you know there is
that other option but certainly if I if
I had just relied on the movie the money
that the movies themself make I probably
would have stopped making movies about
you know 15 years ago okay would you
John I mean you said I'm not one of them
would you go and do a studio movie for
hire I was always sort of had the
impression that that didn't interest you
uh you know
if I like the screenplay and I had
control over the acting in the final cut
short there there's there's five or six
directors who get that you know and once
again I actually had a studio executive
once say-so so why don't you come
directing for us and I said would you
give me final cut and casting control
and and she said if we gave it to you
we'd have to give it to anybody and then
she said that sounds harsh doesn't right
said no I understand you totally you
can't justify you know giving that kind
of control you know in in that corporate
world that you live in to somebody who
hasn't recently made you hundreds of
millions of dollars you know that that's
just you know it is a business well I
just wanted to go back if I could
real quick when you were talking about
the your process working with actors and
I'd ask the question about you know how
you worked on set and he said well the
first thing is casting good actors and
and when you expanded on that I was
curious what is it that when you're in
the room and you're seeing 50 people
come in what is the one thing that if
it's an actor whose work you're not
familiar with and you're meeting them
for the first time in the moment in the
room what is it that says that that you
are drawn to cast that person
I mean if it's that unknown actor and
they get a substantial supporting role
or even you know a leading one on an off
chance what is that thing in the room in
that moment that allows you to make the
decision to say yes I want to cast that
that actor you know it's it's
interesting because sometimes I want to
cast that actor but is is amended with
but not for this production because
they're just not right they're too old
they're too young they're too short
whatever you know for whatever we're
looking for or the chemistry between
them and whoever they're playing
opposite who was already cast is not
right but I try to act with the person
you know I'm usually I don't have a you
know production manager reading the
lines that they're reacting to flat so
that they're looking me in the eye and
the camera you know the video camera is
right next to me
so I'm getting a sense whether as I said
before if you throw them something
different will they react differently
mm-hmm and is is there that that you
know I don't want to see the only thing
they can do in the audition I want to
know that we can go on the set and and
try some new stuff or some new
approaches to a scene or you know who
knows who the actor will be who's in the
scene with them and they're going to be
able to react to that and then the
second thing really is am I paying
attention when you see 50 actors and
sometimes we see 25 actors in a day
you're like a zombie until somebody
wakes you up you know and we really work
hard to make it a good experience for
the actors when they audition but you
know you've seen a lot of people and
you've heard those words before who
aches heal up one of the things I had to
do was I an important part in amigo is
for a woman who who you meet and she has
a line or two and then her daughter is
killed halfway through and then she goes
crazy in the movie she has maybe six
lines total you know and never more than
one or two at a time so there wasn't
really anything I could have this woman
audition for so you know I gave the
actress who came in for it you know I I
wrote a little you know two-page speech
about a woman explaining you know her
daughter getting sick and going to the
hospital and and her daughter just
didn't come out the doctors came out
said your daughter's dead
and I said okay this is the first time
you've said this out loud to anybody
you're gonna be acting in Tagalog you
take this thing that I've just written
on the back of an envelope in English go
in the next room and and a half an hour
come in and tell us this story in
Tagalog as this character and she told
the story and it made me cry and I
didn't understand anything she would say
so it's that other thing is is it's that
almost intangible thing is does this
person make me feel anything we are
truly honored that you are with us here
today and we want to thank you so much
for giving us your time and it's just
been a wonderful
learning experience for us and good luck
to everybody out there in Twitter land
yeah it's tomorrow
is that right that amigo premiers on the
14th 14 yo excuse me I do interviews
tomorrow and we're looking for
distribution like everybody else you
know so that that's one of the nice
things about the Toronto Film Festival
it's a place where we've often been able
to you know find a distributor for a
movie very nice well thank you and our
our audience is excited to see your
latest work done and we certainly hope
that that you'll find time in the future
to rejoin us here in film cards when we
thank you for being here today
and and and thank you for your lifetime
of work that you've given to all of us
thank you okay thank you thank you and
thank you to Dan denell Myron for
arranging this interview and with that
have a great week